it's disgusting it's despicable you know
at the time many people couldn't see
their loved ones who were dying the
british public were told to do the right
thing to keep people safe to look after
their relatives and we find out that an
email to over 100 people was sent out
from downing street saying come along to
our party bring your own booze the
weather's nice i mean it can only be
described as
something that will make everyone angry
you know the prime minister should know
better you know we're in a time of
crisis and we need good leadership and
what we got is somebody who was good at
telling lies and fibs and has actually
smirked about some of these issues when
doing interviews and i think the british
public now have just about had enough
now we've got a name on the email of
course the sender martin reynolds the
principal private secretary to the prime
minister and government sources uh
suggesting today that uh he should have
been more careful he was meant to be
protecting downing street staff yet he
yet he sent this out do you think he's
been lined up as the fall guy well he
can't be the fall guy because we know
that you know there's multiple
allegations now around parties and the
culture that was happening around
downing street at the time and that
comes back to the prime minister and i
think it's disgraceful you can't get out
of this one this is very clear that you
shouldn't have been doing it people were
in devastating situations i lost
relatives during the pandemic as many
did and many people now who are still
grieving the loss of their loved ones
will be feeling heartbroken that not
only did the prime minister think it was
okay to throw parties at number 10 but
he was also trying to deceive the public
by saying he had nothing to do with it
that's despicable it's disgraceful and
he should be absolutely ashamed of
himself well he was asked about it today
and he didn't confirm or deny whether he
was at it or not um if he were
at that party what would your reaction
be he should go i mean if he was at that
party i mean he shouldn't have been
allowing parties to happen in number ten
i find it shocking some of these
responses that he's had to i didn't know
about it you know it wasn't on my watch
well it clearly was there was more than
one party happening in the heart of
government and i find it absolutely
astonishing that the prime minister
thinks that he had nothing to do with it
didn't know anything about it
i think you know he needs to reflect on
his behaviors and reflect on what he's
done to the british public you know
let's be explicit here you say he needs
to reflect on his behavior but in your
view he'd have to reflect out of office
if he was at that party labor is calling
for the prime minister to resign i i
mean it'd be no shock to anyone
listening to this program that i don't
think the prime minister's fit to govern
but i think the most important thing now
is the british public have lost
confidence in the prime minister and if
the prime minister was at this party
then i think it's the british public
that will be demanding and the fact that
his mps are allowing him to carry on as
the prime minister just shows the
contempt that the conservatives have for
the british public who were doing the
right thing at the time and we're
keeping their loved ones safe and many
of them didn't even get to say goodbye
and i think that's something that the
prime minister should think on not just
about his career but about as a human
being and about what you what you'd say
to people in their hour of need when
they need that support when they're
looking for that level of leadership you
let them down
so badly that's what you should be
reflecting just let me ask you about the
process i know you have confidence in
the investigation that's been carried
out by sue graves looking into not just
these allegations but other ones as well
but just be very clear that if sue grey
his recommendation is that martin
reynolds should resign after this she
would say that's not enough it must be
the prime minister as well i think if
the prime minister knew about this party
attended this party and all the other
evidence and the parties that have been
alleged has happened all of that
evidence if the law has been broken
should be handed over to the police and
nobody is above the law in this country
and they should be dealt with
appropriately but this isn't a one-off
now this is endemic people are saying
you know this memes about how many
parties number 10 have had because
people are so like you know they're so
upset by what the government have done
it's astonishing that a time of crisis
that this government thinks it's okay to
laugh at the british people and think
there's one rule for them and one rule
for everybody else well that's not how
we stand up in this country that's not
what we stand for and the prime minister
needs to reflect upon that are you
saying to the metropolitan police you
touched on it there i mean this was the
law at the time and if the law has been
broken you would want the metropolitan
police to launch a criminal
investigation absolutely and nobody is
above the law in this country if the law
has been broken the metropolitan police
should be dealing with that yes and i
think that sue gray should give that
information over to the police if
there's evidence the police should look
at that and that they should deal with
it as they would do any other member of
the public during that period and let's
not forget many members of the public
did get dealt with criminally as part of
what happened in covid so therefore i
don't think boris johnson should be
dealt with any differently i mean you
mentioned there just how angry some
people are sky news has been talking to
a woman who's actually in the back
garden of downing street in invited
there to talk about how she lost one of
her relatives yeah it's devastating i
mean people going back to may and and
around that time in may it was the eid
celebrations of course and many people
had to sacrifice those celebrations that
are very important to them so a lot of
people made huge sacrifices not seeing
their loved ones when they were dying
and it will anger people because the
prime minister has a responsibility if
he's telling people to follow the rules
then surely the very least he could do
was follow those rules himself and
create a culture around government that
says these rules are serious we're
asking people to make big sacrifices we
should be doing the same i've got to put
in there though but of course you know
they were working terribly hard in
downing street of course they were and
and the fact that there were a lot of
people there of course we were being
told well you know many people at the
time but they they had to be there but
let me see not parties absolutely but
many of our members of the nhs
were sacrificing not seeing their loved
ones some people our care workers were
intense and not seeing their family so
that they could look after elderly
people many people made huge sacrifices
who were working incredibly hard at that
at the time keeping our country going
they didn't throw parties they were
seeing the effects of covid seeing
people dying and choking in hospitals so
for the prime minister and people around
him to be throwing parties at the time
the death rates were as high as they
were and people were told that they
couldn't see their loved ones when they
were dying i think that is the worst
thing you could possibly expect the
prime minister have been doing at that
time we can only speculate about this
but if remembering at the time there
seemed to be an awful lot of people in
and around downing street including
obviously the the prime minister uh
dominic cummings and others who caught
covid at the time does this perhaps
provide part of the explanation well i i
don't know why people were catching
covered at the time around down the
street people should have been in work
if they needed to be in work as
essential workers i as you say many of
our key workers did i pay tribute to
them and the work that they continue to
do this flies in the face of that when
they find out that they were working
really hard 12-hour shifts looking after
people who were dying the prime minister
and people around him were throwing a
party in number 10 that's not okay